Jenna you're getting my one spoiler
question in this interview because the
the chat and Tara relationship is a
pretty big new element of the movie here
so what excited you most about adding
that connection for Tara but maybe not
in a way that's just like adding romance
for the sake of adding romance but
rather that connection being something
that helps the character evolve in a
meaningful way I think it just great
question I think it's just
um yeah being able to add that layer for
Tara and I think because we've only ever
seen her in distress for four hours now
I think it's really wonderful for her to
have some sort of relief and especially
in a character as as lovely and um
coolest Chad also in the fifth one we
had no interaction at all I don't think
we ever talked to each other I don't
think so I remember Mason and I being
really surprised but then also really
pleasantly surprised when we got to work
with one another because fortunately
enough we kind of get along and um it's
uh yeah I think it's it's I mean any
sort of relationship is good for the
evolution of a person so I think that
seeing Tara also have that added layer I
think it adds um Dimension and makes her
more interesting well I guess speaking
of that I'll put up the spoiler warning
for this and we will save it until the
appropriate time but the Chad and Tara
relationship is a pretty big new element
of the series so what was it about that
connection that you were most excited to
get to explore in a way that it wasn't
just like a relationship for the sake of
having a relationship in the movie but
it actually you know furthers his
character Arc I love I think that says a
lot about Tara and Chad that they would
find love and to a certain extent
romance in a on text that is so raw with
like Peril and danger and fear and I
think it has subtle nods to the
suggestion that like love will always
Prevail and
um we'll do what we can to protect the
people we love and we care about and
that's Chad to a T and uh Tara certainly
tried her best
but um but uh thankfully Chad has some
sort of Eldritch God within him that
keeps him from dying dying so
uh bless him for it he is he's
channeling a little dewy I I hope that
run lasts even longer than it did for
Dewey oh now my heart is breaking I have
one more question that I wanted to
include in the spoiler part of the
conversation so you could answer it
freely but I love talking about the
value of a good scene partner so can
each of you name a Time on set when a
scene partner helps you access something
in your own character that you wouldn't
have been able to reach without them
that's a great question
um the hospital scene was a moment where
I guess there wasn't a lot of dialogue
exchange between
I'm going to use Jasmine because she's
here now where between Jasmine and I but
where we had to channel like a moment of
like fear and distress because Gail had
just been attacked and
this I have a younger sister uh who's
not my twin but a sister nonetheless and
the fear you have for wanting their
safety to be secure
uh as a sibling and as a loved one I
think something about Jasmine's delivery
of like I don't want to get is it I
don't want to get hurt again I don't
want to think so it broke my heart and
it made it so easy to sort of just find
that emotional Bedrock from where the
scene would okay yeah I didn't say much
so I just looked bad but you made it
easy thank you I'll throw it back to him
and I'll also point out how amazing
David nakota is in this film and I
really hope that this launches her in a
New Direction in her acting career um
but she is so easy and so fun to work
off of she was really making me scared
and sad and those things to put it
lightly and I'm excited for everyone to
get to know her work that's
heartbreaking oh my God so good the
feelings leap off the screen I very much
felt the same way congratulations
congratulations
did you cry off camera I'll tell you
about when I cry I feel like a big old
dope but I I might have been a little
teary at the end this is my favorite
franchise of all time so when I get a
really good movie in it and I mean it
genuinely means a lot to me and it did
well that's what we do it
Right
congratulations I will hopefully see you
both soon and thanks to everyone behind
the scenes I appreciate your time today